asean foreign ministers ain't phen
hoping to find solutions to deal with
the crisis in myanmar
cambodian prime minister hunsen in his
opening remarks admitted the situation
in military-run myanmar can even be said
to have deteriorated after last month's
execution of four anti-coup activists
in case there are any more prisoners who
will be executed
then we will reconsider our roles in the
agreed 5 points consensus opposition
the asean-led peace plan was agreed in
april last year but since then there's
been little progress
myanmar once again is absent from the
meeting after asean members barred its
military-appointed foreign minister from
attending extending the invite to a
non-political representative instead
some diplomats have admitted myanmar's
absence at the regional meeting may make
it more difficult to find a solution
there's also pressure from civil rights
groups and some members of parliament in
asean countries for the organization to
do more to resolve the situation in
myanmar many have suggested it's time
for asean to engage with the national
unity government a shadow civilian
government made up of those who oppose
the coup
myanma will not be the only item on the
agenda in phnom penh
in the next few days top diplomats from
the u.s russia china and other countries
will also be here for ministerial
meetings with their asean colleagues
asean has to deal with challenges
of different types and level
but never before
never like this year
never like this moment
have we been confronted
at the same time with so many perils
for the region
and the world at large
russia's invasion of ukraine tensions in
the taiwan strait the competition
between the us and china these are all
matters that will occupy the delegates
in the next few days
florence louis al jazeera phnom penh